the
2668 billionaires on forbes 2022 world's
billionaires list have established their
fortunes in all sorts of ways
building pet food and soy sauce brands
mining copper and zinc making eyeglasses
and developing real estate empires some
created new riches some inherited old
ones
these are the industries that minted the
most billionaires in 2022 as well as the
richest person in each of the ten
categories
this year the industry with the most
billionaires is finance and investments
with 393 billionaires nearly 15 percent
of the list that's an increase from last
year when finance and investments was
also the top industry with 371 list
members the sector encompasses hedge
fund and private equity tycoons
traditional bankers and fintech founders
money managers venture capitalists and
billionaires who've made investments in
a variety of sectors
the richest in this industry warren
buffett ceo of investing conglomerate
berkshire hathaway is now worth an
estimated 118 billion dollars 22 billion
dollars more than last year and the
fifth richest person in the world others
rising in finance are not yet household
names
chan pen zhao known as cz is the second
richest person in finance on this year's
list
cz founded cryptocurrency exchange
binance which has grown to become one of
the world's largest
it's been a year plagued by supply chain
slowdowns including the high profile
sinkings of more than one cargo ship but
manufacturing follows finance and
investment as the second highest
industry for billionaires with 337
demand from consumers and businesses for
goods didn't slow helping manufacturing
to mint 36 new billionaires the richest
of the pack is he shinjang the founder
of appliance maker media group the
technology industry lauded for driving
innovation globally accounts for 332
billionaires making it the third largest
industry this year down one from last
year tech fortunes from the early
internet era still hold the top spots
today the 10 biggest fortunes from tech
are from the founders of companies like
google oracle and microsoft all launched
decades ago but no one is more rich than
amazon's jeff bezos forbes previously
categorized social media tycoons as
being from the tech industry but this
year we have shifted the founders of
facebook instagram pinterest snapchat
and tick tock parent bite dance to the
media and entertainment industry to
better reflect how those companies are
functioning next up were retailers with
250 tycoons who got rich from a mix of
businesses including luxury brands
sportswear companies and grocery chains
bayonna arno remains at the top worth an
estimated 158 billion dollars as head of
luxury conglomerate lvmh which owns
brands like hennessey and louis vuitton
falguni nair india's richest self-made
woman joins the list at an estimated 4.5
billion dollars after building beauty
and fashion retailer nika which went
public last november healthcare ranks
fifth on our industry list with 217
billionaires cyrus punawala is the
richest in this category with a net
worth of 24.3 billion dollars
he is the founder of serum institute of
india the world's largest vaccine maker
by doses jeff tangni is the top newcomer
worth an estimated 2.4 billion dollars
after founding doximeter a social
platform for doctors that went public
last june
the food and beverage industry also
accounts for eight percent of the
world's billionaires
the richest in this category is zhang
chan chan who has a net worth of 65.7
billion dollars he's the chairman of
bottled water company ngfu spring and he
also controls the publicly listed
beijing wontai biological pharmacy
real estate ranks number seven with 193
billionaires china's li xiaoki is the
wealthiest within the industry before he
co-founded property development company
sun hong kai he started henderson land
development which makes up the majority
of his wealth there are 180 billionaires
whose fortunes come from diversified
holdings the wealthiest of these being
mukesh ambani the chairman of reliance
industries the firm holds interests in
petrochemicals oil and gas retail and
telecommunications only four percent of
the list falls under media and
entertainment former mayor of new york
and presidential candidate michael
bloomberg stands out with a net worth of
82 billion dollars he co-founded
financial information and media company
bloomberg lp and the sector coming in at
number 10 is energy only 95 of the
world's billionaires work within the
industry but fan hung way of china leads
the pack with a net worth of 18.2
billion dollars
she's the chair of fiber supplier henley
petrochemical which makes polyester and
textiles
while glamorous industries like sports
media and entertainment can mint many
millionaire athletes actors and
producers those whose fortune rise to
the billions are usually the select few
with ownership stakes in lucrative
brands and companies the sports industry
has three new billionaires this year
including red sox chairman tom werner
and arizona diamondback's managing
general partner ken kendrick but out of
the 27 billionaires in sports only one
was a professional athlete michael
jordan who is worth an estimated 1.7
billion dollars thanks to his stake in
the charlotte hornets
you